what is your number one advice for
winning a street fight
and do you have any stories
gang gang damn
yeah might even where you become a
fighter then people want to fight you
that's probably one of the problems of
being a fighter like if you if you want
to be a
nobody wants to eat your cookies until
you say you're a bake you know what i'm
saying brother but then once you
once they see that oven open people want
to come and see what's up they want a
snickerdoodle my first advice is don't
fight the street
it's horrible
you have a lot of scratching your elbows
in your knees
um you don't win nothing yeah you don't
stop for the cars it's not glory it's
not glory there man right
i i have just won a street fight in all
my life i had
15 or 16 years old
and i went to play soccer to some field
and we always playing there and some guy
from he looks like very like from the
hood like
even a kind of homeless really he looks
like yeah like from the hood like
like yeah no casa exactly he looks weird
like yeah
he looks good problems yeah and he
started to play with problems
and he started to play to play with him
yeah he looked at probably and he
started to play with us soccer we all
the guys
he he came with a few with a few friends
i remember like one or two i don't know
and we start to play on everything
and at some point he has the ball
and i take the the ball from
his legs
and he started to get mad because i i
was doing that like cons constantly yeah
okay and in the last one i take the ball
he's here i i had the ball
and he's tried to take me the the ball
like bad like
oh slide you down exactly but i move the
ball there and he's just like a slide on
all the ground like a cartoon exactly
and then he
he go against me like
he started to scream to my face and
everything
so i i saw the the problem there and
like when i put my hands up i don't i
don't care i in that moment i i had like
two or three years experience of or
making martial arts
and
and then i put my hands up
he put his
hands up
and he started to move a little bit
everybody man i throw a job
and with the job he went to the ground
i don't remember if he started to
throw some blood yeah maybe i don't
remember but i remember he went to the
ground like boom
and i don't feel good man i don't i feel
like ugh
because when i fall when i fight with
some guy who
uh i know the guy know how to fight
right and i beat him like okay that's
different it's fair yeah like okay so is
it because you think it's more fair yeah
right yeah because i don't i don't feel
good when i do that like right i
remember that i i saw the guy in the
ground like oh man that's fine i don't
want more promise man everything is fine
and they can i go out of the of the
field and i went to my house and i feel
weird like i don't know i don't
i don't and he didn't couldn't even go
to his house because he was
he was probably homeless you know maybe
he couldn't even go to his house
he couldn't even go after him oh oh so
yeah myself so for you fighting there's
something so you you really like to
fight if it's very organized and it's
fair
yeah okay so it's not for you you don't
like to because it's interesting some
guys just love to [ __ ] fight like i
talk with cheeto very he just loves guys
he's crazy that is crazy he's crazy
right yeah he knows he's being crazy he
loves [ __ ] you know he's just he
loves to fight you know and like poirier
i think sometimes he like he loves to
scrap too but i think he likes to fight
he wants to prove himself kind of like
um
but so you like to fight why do you like
to fight you think
for the same the same with like like
prayer
i like to prove i i i love
when the people
when i
i watch people from now from the school
you know from high school from middle
school and like hey
i never thought you you would be a
fighter a real fighter wow
like
i love that because
i proved they they were they were wrong
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy
two
options watch one this one or this one
you